some of the most familiar faces in
Westeros have changed a lot during the
course of Game of Thrones run on HBO
over the course of the series several of
the show's key actors have ended up
being replaced leading fans to wonder
just what really happened throughout the
entire series emilia clarke has shined
as Daenerys Targaryen from a mild young
bride to the fierce and ruthless warrior
she is today Daenerys has been through
one of the show's most exciting arcs and
without Clarke's portrayal far fewer
viewers would have fallen in love with
the character the way that they have
hailed as a feminist icon fans have been
gripped by Daenerys his finest moments
and Clarke herself has achieved
international recognition for the role
as well as nominations for several
awards I'm not going to stop the wheel
I'm going to break the wheel with that
in mind it might seem difficult to
believe that anyone else ever could have
played Daenerys but in the initially
troubled pilot for Game of Thrones
Daenerys was originally played by Tenzin
merchant best known for her role as
Henry the eighth's fifth wife Catherine
Howard on the Tudors creators David
Benioff and DB Weiss have been open
about their disdain for the original
pilot but neither the two showrunners
nor casting director Nina Gould have
fully discussed the reason for merchants
exit today fans are left to wonder just
how different the series might have been
with a different Daenerys riding those
dragons Game of Thrones is third season
introduced a new potential love interest
for Daenerys in the form of Daario
naharis played by IDI screen this clever
long-haired mercenary was obviously
interested in Daenerys from day one and
when he betrayed his own men to join her
sighs it became clear that Dario's
machinations would make him an even
bigger player in the seasons to come
after a three episode arc in the third
season however screen was
unceremoniously replaced when McHale
Houseman as it turned out screen had run
into a scheduling issue as he was set to
appear in the new transporter film the
actor has since admitted that it wasn't
the easiest decision but that he had no
regrets and leaving Game of Thrones
luckily for Houseman he quickly became
yet another one of the show's beloved
key players and his romance with
Daenerys left many wondering where he
might end up as the show concludes in
the early seasons of Game of Thrones
viewers discovered that Cersei Lannister
'he's three children all of
were supposedly of baratheon blood were
actually bastards born of her incestuous
affair with her twin brother Jamie
however nobody paid much attention to
any of the children besides Joffrey
Cersei eldest and most wicked child who
eventually ascended to the throne and
wreaked a significant amount of havoc on
King's Landing in Westeros as a whole as
a result the other two supposed
Baratheon children were often shunted to
the side making it easy for them to be
recast as required a frequent reality
when dealing with young actors whose
growth easily put them out of sync with
the show's pacing because of these age
issues Tommen Baratheon was recast in
the show's fourth season and when it was
time for him to take the crown from
Joffrey calum where he was replaced by
Dean Charles Chapman Chapman went on to
handle many of the mild King Tommen's
more difficult scenes including a love
scene with his new wife Margaery Tyrell
as well as his death at the end of the
sixth season however many fans might
have recognized Chapman's face from
somewhere since he had actually appeared
in the show's third season playing a
young Lannister squire who was held
hostage by the Starks and eventually
killed by Rickard Karstark this actually
gives Chapman a rare distinction of
having played two separate roles during
the show's run and having died twice -
much like Tommen Cersei Lannister 'he's
middle child Marcella went largely
overlooked until later seasons of
Thrones Marcella was essentially left
out of the plot entirely until the
second season when her uncle Tyrion
decided to send her to Dorne creating a
permanent rift between Tyrion and Cersei
in the fifth season she reappeared as a
lovestruck teenager engaged to trystane
Martell the young prince of Dorne thanks
to an ongoing battle between the
Lannister and Martell families she ended
up murdered at the hands of ilaria sand
shortly after she discovered her true
parentage though Marcella was played by
the young actress Amy Richardson during
her appearances in the early seasons
when she returned she was played by the
dynamic Nell tiger free much like Tom
and strategic recasting this can likely
be chalked up to discrepancies between
the growth of the actor and her
character as the older of the
much-feared Clegane brothers the
mountain is one of Westeros is most
terrifying warriors and although he has
kind of managed to make it through the
entire series so far he has nonetheless
undergone a cig
transformation along the way once a
formidable fighter known for his
penchant for committing war crimes on
behalf of the Lannisters the mountain
was nearly felled by a poisoned spear
tip during his duel with Oberyn Martell
in season four after that however he was
turned into a kind of mute zombie loyal
only to Cersei herself but that wasn't
the only transformation that the
mountain has undergone during Game of
Thrones run as he's actually been played
by no fewer than three separate actors
in season one when the mountain nearly
killed Loras Tyrell after a joust he was
played by conan stevens and australian
actor the mountain was far less visible
in season two but when he did appear he
was played by the Welsh actor Ian White
from the fourth season on the fearsome
and intimidating icelandic strongmen
half thor ulis bjornsen has portrayed
the mountain of course now that he's in
sconce tin an iron mask it doesn't seem
to matter much that this massive man has
changed faces three times the Tarly
family isn't exactly the most important
plan in Westeros but astute viewers will
have gotten to know them pretty well
over the years by far the most
significant member of the family is
Samwell Tarly the lovable bookworm of
the Nights Watch and frequent companion
to Jon Snow Sam has proven to be the
heart and soul of the show time and time
again but he's not so popular among his
own family in the sixth season when Sam
arrived at horn Hill with his girlfriend
Gilly he received a cold welcome from
his Stern father Randall who clearly
favors Sam's handsome and accomplished
brother dick on not far enough already
during season six Freddie stroma of
Harry Potter Fame appeared as dick on
however scheduling issues forced him out
of the show so black sails Tom hopper
stepped in to plenty of acclaim from
fans
sadly hoppers time as dick on has also
been cut short as both he and his father
Randall were burned alive by Daenerys
when they refused to bend the knee to
her in season seven easy come easy go
most viewers of the show will be
familiar with Stannis Baratheon who as
King Robert Baratheon's brother
staunchly believed he was the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne but some might
not remember his wife Sully's Baratheon
while Stannis fought for the throne with
the aid of Melisandre selys remained
nothing if not loyal
after all she stuck by her husband
several unsuccessful battles as well as
his obvious attraction to Melisandre
herself when Stannis used their daughter
Shireen as a human sacrifice
Selyse finally took her own life only
for Stannis to meet his final defeat in
battle a few hours later
Sully's when she was introduced was a
very minor character who can be spotted
simply standing in the vicinity of
Melisandre and Stannis while the latter
commits himself to the Lord of Light
during a magical ceremony in the second
season's premiere at that time she was
played by Sara McKeever had no lines at
all and served as little more than a
glorified extra however when Celia's
role was expanded to include a
multi-episode arc the show chose a more
venerated actress for the role Tara
Fitzgerald who famously appeared
opposite ray Fiennes in Hamlet on
Broadway during the mid-1990s Game of
Thrones first episode ended on a pretty
shocking final scene specifically the
young brand stark being pushed out of a
tall tower after catching Jaime and
Cersei in a compromising position bran
survived the fall however losing his
mobility and eventually gaining a new
set of powers including the ability to
review and even metal and events of the
very distant past making him the heir
apparent to the role of the three-eyed
Raven when the audience finally met the
mysterious three-eyed Raven in season
four he looked fairly different to the
character fans would later come to know
originally played by stru and Roger bran
first meets the Raven while the
omniscient being is holed up in a
secluded tree by the time the three-eyed
Raven returned to the show in its sixth
season Roger had been replaced by
legendary actor Max von Sydow
best known for the Exorcist in Flash
Gordon since then it has been von Sydow
Raven who has guided brand through the
secrets of the past present and future
of Westeros Game of Thrones is rife with
villains and antagonists but few are
more sinister or more mysterious than
the night king the ancient and seemingly
infallible leader of the White Walkers
the walkers who reside far north of a
wall that separates Westeros from the
northern wilderness were previously
considered nothing more than a
frightening legend but have recently
made their presence known in Westeros in
a pretty spectacular way throughout the
show's run audiences have watched the
night King perform a range of despicable
acts from turning a child sacrifice
to a white Walker to taking down one of
Daenerys his beloved dragons though the
character comes to life via impressive
prosthetic makeup as the show went on
sharp-eyed viewers realized that the
night king looked a little different
from when we first met him before season
6 the night King was played by Richard
Blake but the role then went of Vladimir
furred ik an actor hailing from Slovakia
though the show's creators have never
provided a concrete reason for the
change it's possible that verdict won
the role thanks to his history as a
stuntman giving him more mobility for
battle scenes throughout thrones' run
beric Dondarrion has quite literally
lived several lives in season 1 he
served as nothing more than a member of
a search party sent by Ned Stark to
bring the mountain to justice as war
broke out in Westeros however he joined
a group called the Brotherhood without
banners who through their loyalty to the
Lord of Light have followed Barrack as
he has constantly revived from the dead
by his resident red priest
Thoros of mere most recently Barrack has
been found aiding Jon Snow in his fight
against the white walkers travelling
north of the wall in order to get more
information on these mysterious and
ancient creatures David Michael Scott
portrayed barrack for his minor role
during the first season beginning in
season 3 however Irish actor Richard
dormer took the reins
luckily barracks change in appearance is
easy enough to explain in universe
considering the man died multiple times
off screen before viewers met him for
the second time again check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Game of Thrones
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you'll miss
a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]